we talked about life a lot
what do you think is the meaning of it
all what's the meaning of life
i mean my answer is probably going to be
pretty cheesy um
but i think the state of love is once
you feel it
um in a way that we discussed it before
i'm not talking about falling in love or
um
just love to yourself to to other people
to
something to the world that state of
bliss that we experience sometimes
whether through connection
with ourselves with our people with the
technology
there's something special about those
those moments so um
i would say if anything that's that's
the only if it's not for that then for
for what else are we really trying to do
that
i don't think there's a better way to
end it than talking about love
eugenia i told you um offline that
there was something about me that felt
like this
this was this talking to you meeting you
in person will be a turning point
for my life i know that might be
something weird just to hear
but it's it was a huge honor to talk to
you
i hope we talk again thank you so much
for your time thank you so much
you